[Music]
i'm father joshua caswell
i know many of you here we have some
visitors as well i'm a pastor here at
saint john catches church
and here at saint john kansas church in
chicago we're very proud to offer the
very best in philosophy
catechetics culture and art
today's speaker
is certainly one who meets that standard
jonathan pajot
graduated with distinction
from the painting and drawing program at
concordia university in montreal during
the late 1990s
quickly disillusioned with contemporary
art he discovered icons and traditional
christian images along his own spiritual
journey
rekindling his love of art through study
of traditional forms
jonathan developed a passion for wood
carving
jonathan delivers lectures every year at
universities conferences and other
venues around north america
he speaks on art but mostly on the
symbolic structures that underlie our
experience of the world
through his well-known youtube channel
and podcast
the symbolic world
he also furthers the conversation on
symbolism meaning and patterns and
everything from movies to icons to
social trends
yesterday evening he spoke to us a bit
about kanye west's new album
yesterday evening jonathan presented to
the catholic art guild and today he
shares an overview of his thought
christian life
and symbolic living so without further
ado
i welcome jonathan pusho
[Applause]
so hello everybody
um
it was a great evening last night i got
to visit the church it's pretty amazing
very beautiful
and there's something about
um
something about the uh groundedness of
the church in the sense there's a folk
element to some of the art you know
these polychromed statues i love that
you have all these polychrome statues
there's there came to be a hatred of
polychrome at some point in our in our
age but the
the color of the um of the altar and the
small chapel just the the gold and the
color and and it's an exuberance right
it's a it's a
celebration
and
it's that celebratory aspect that i want
to talk about with you today
one of the things that
people don't realize
when you come to church you know we come
to church for our reasons we come to
church to commune with god to commune
with people but
have you ever thought about
the possibility that when you you come
to church you you're actually
participating the in the existence of
the world
and i can say that and you might have
heard someone say that
that we participate in the existence of
the world
through prayer
and sometimes it can sound a little bit
a bit woo-woo or just kind of spiritual
in a vague sense where we we say it but
we don't know what it means but i i'm
i want to say technically
almost
almost let's say scientifically
when you come to church you participate
in the existence of the world
one of the things that people have
realized
recently let's say
the modern world has been
characterized by science we all know and
science has been
uh you know whether it's true or not has
been one of the bludgeons that the
modern world has used to
hit at traditional christianity to hit
on religion
through all kinds of means
and one of the things that happened is
that
the scientists talked about the world
out there
talked about phenomena and and analyzing
phenomena representing phenomena trying
to show mechanical causes of everything
and thinking that because they found the
mechanical cause of something that
somehow it takes away its meaning
and they did that they did that and they
keep getting deeper into the world
deeper into the world and at some point
some people started to realize oh
well there's one thing that we haven't
talked about there's one thing that we
haven't really explained and that's
consciousness
we use consciousness we use intelligence
to
discover science and to discover the
world and to smash on christianity and
just match on religion but one of the
things we haven't done
is understand consciousness so maybe we
should do that maybe we should try to
understand consciousness
and then as the eye tried to turn and to
look back inside
everything started to get very very
strange
and all the things that looked very
stable started to not look as stable as
they did before
and as scientists started to analyze
human perception
because at some point you realize wait a
minute we're actually we are people
looking at the world
we're not it's not just the world out
there we have to we have to take in for
into account the fact that we are the
people looking at it so we have to try
to analyze the eye that's looking
and they realize that things are a lot
more
complicated and
it has opened the door
to re-understand our religious practices
in a way that that is surprising to many
one of the things that
one of the things that the
scientists are realizing as they're
studying consciousness for example is
that when we look at at the world we
don't actually see
things
in themselves
because the problem is that
things in themselves
they they scatter into detail if you
really take the time to look at it
anything like a microphone i always use
a microphone because it's in front of me
it's like the microphone that's in front
of me has a million details in it
there are millions of aspects just in
this microphone
every little piece of wire every every
speck of paint
and then i could go deeper and all the
molecules that that make it and then all
the atoms that make it it scatters into
detail
why why why can i say that this is a
microphone how do i do that
and it's the same for everything
everything is i could spend hours and
hours talking about just the just the
corner of my cuff because there's a
thousand
threads in
in my cuff and then there's a thousand
little threads in that thread and it
just keeps getting
just breaks down into detail
and the problem is how do we know that
something is one
and it's not just not just a microphone
it scales up
it's how do i know that a family is one
thing
because it's a bunch of people
what's the difference between a family
and a random group of strangers that
that cross each other on the street how
do i how can i say that that's one thing
because it's obviously many things
and then you can keep scaling up how do
i know that a city is one thing
how can i say that how can i say chicago
and think that that actually exists in
the world
how can i say united states of america
and so what they're realizing is that
what we actually look at when we're
looking at the world even in terms of
the based sense but in this in
especially in the way we understand it
is that we see
purposes
right and we we have a a magic capacity
to
cohere all the details into unities
and they use a word they say emergence
they say there's emergence so there's
all this complexity and out of this
complexity something emerges as one but
it's like they don't understand that
it's just a magic word they use to
describe something they don't understand
how is it that there's a bunch of stuff
and now there's one how is it that i
that we can say that
and what's fascinating
is that
once you understand that
once you understand that then you
realize that
we
are part of how things come together as
humans we are made in the image of god
we believe that as christians
we are made in the image of god there's
this story in in genesis where adam
names the animals
and you can understand it that way
you have all these all this bunch of
stuff coming crawling towards adam all
these beasts all these things and then
he picks out and he says that's one
thing that's that that's that and he
names the animals and that's what human
beings do
and one of the things that the
scientists are realizing is that
if there wasn't human beings naming
things
we're not quite sure what actually would
exist
because it all breaks down all the way
to the quantum field or whatever it all
breaks down into all this all this just
possibility of existence
now this sound might seem very very
abstract what i'm saying but if you
bring it back to
people because that's easier for us to
understand because we're people
right
what's the difference between a bunch of
people
that are in the same space
and a people that actually have a group
and are
are
an identity that have an identity what's
the difference
and the difference is what you're
participating in when you come to church
when you come to church you have all
this diverse bunch of people everybody
has their story everybody has their
reality their problems their their their
economic status all of this is all this
multiplicity which exists and everybody
has their own problems and their own
thing and what are we doing when we come
to church
to a certain extent we are setting that
aside
all that
noise let's say
and we are
focusing
in together
on the same thing
and that's it
that that's how
a community exists any community
for something to be a community there
has to be something that makes you
brings you in common with the other
people that are in a community now it
can be it could be that you i don't know
that you collect stamps you know it
could be that it's a knitting group and
everybody that's in the knitting group
knits
like they're all kinds of purposes that
would make a group cohere
but the thing about the church is that
we
scale that up
to the highest possible purpose
so the knitting group is fine you know
and these little groups are fine but
when we come to church what we're doing
is we are
bringing that up we're that's when we
know we're giving glory to god
we're worshiping the highest possible
thing
so because we're worshiping the highest
possible thing because we're all
together for the same reason which is to
look up together and to be part to to to
acknowledge the highest thing
then it then it becomes the
becomes the anchor
of
reality
and you know if i had said that if i'd
said that to you 100 years ago a lot of
people wouldn't would have said yeah you
know whatever like
this is just magical thinking you're
just you're just it's just superstition
but no no no
because we've had a hundred years now
of people that have tried to destroy
that
and we have seen the results
what's the result the result is the
suburbs that's the result
the result is a bunch of houses
spread out on land
with a bunch of highways connecting
these houses to strip malls into and to
and to things and there is no
coherence
those those those huge swaths of houses
that are out there
and and have you know and then people go
to malls and go to big huge grocery
stores
they are not communities
and we know it because we because i live
in a suburb myself you guys probably
live in the city i live in the suburb
and i barely know my neighbors i know
maybe the neighbor that's like one house
down maybe two houses down i know them
say hello that's about it
but
four houses down i don't know them
but now let's take a let's take a
traditional structure let's look at a
medieval village
or a medieval town
or a town you know i'm from quebec a
town a hundred a hundred years ago in
quebec where i'm from which used to be
the most catholic place in the world by
the way and not anymore
um
how is it town i was living so last year
we were
my family i were flooded and we had to
move and we moved into this small town
called senplacid which is uh was about
30 minutes away further out into
um to the boonies and
this this town i'll tell you about the
town the town
the first thing in the town that was
built was what do you think
the church
the church was built before the town
and that is not a rare thing to happen
in the history of the west where the
first thing to be built is a church the
church is built for different reasons
sometimes in the early church the church
was built because a martyr died there
and the church becomes and the the place
of the death of the martyr when you say
that the martyrs the blood of the
martyrs is the seed of the church that's
literally how it happens a martyr dies
they build a church and all of a sudden
people start living around the church
and houses start to build around the
church and then people's you know and
then out a bit further out you need
farmland because people need to eat you
end up having
fields a little further out and then
next to the church well then at some
point if there's a lot of people we need
some kind of you know public square
build a public square build a market
have a government type building you know
the mayor's office or whatever so you
have the center of town that has the
church
and then has all the things that bring
us together
the church the the public office the
public space
and the church is
always
higher
than everything else in the town that's
not arbitrary
it's not arbitrary that the church is
the highest thing why is it the highest
thing
right it's the highest thing so you can
so that you can see it from wherever you
are
so there's one thing
that if we look in that direction
everybody in the town
is reminded of what brings them together
so on sundays the whole town comes
together
they go to church they participate in
this this coming together and you can
see it as
what i described you can see it almost
like this onion
that gets peeled back
so you you have outside of the town you
have the farmland then you have the town
then in the middle you have all the
public institutions and then in the
church now
you have the nave where we are and then
you have the altar
and then in the altar in the sanctuary
you have the altar and then on the table
of the altar you have the cup and then
in the cup you have this invisible
transformation you have this spark of
divinity which is the reason why we're
there together
and and how do we know that how do we
know that that's happening one of the
ways we know is that it's the reason why
we actually exist
as a town
it's making us all with all our
differences all our problems all our
little fights all of this which remains
there but as we come together and we say
the same words we pray the same prayers
we all look in the same direction we are
manifesting that unity
it's so much easier for me to say that
today so much easier for me to say that
today because sadly we have now seen
the
the opposite we have seen that when you
don't have that
you have this fragmentation which occurs
we have people who slip
and and and slip uh between the cracks
like do you think do you think that
there could be this is
this is a tough thing to say but do you
think that in a
medieval town
there could happen that something like a
school shooter would appear
it's not possible
it's not possible because the network of
knowledge
goes all the way to the edge of the town
you have a wall around the city you have
this coherent thing which is all
participating together and so the
anomalies will be identified
nobody was completely slip into the
cracks because everybody is
interconnected to a certain way
but in a world where you have all these
suburban houses sprawled out in these
massive apartment buildings you can have
someone who's there and that no one ever
talks to ever and no one notices
at all
and so
i think that that is something that we
need to remember because sometimes you
don't want to go to church sometimes you
wonder why are we doing this i'm sure
none of you ever wondered that i
sometimes will have that little moment
where i'm like you know is it really
worth it is it is it you know is it
worth all the effort everything and the
answer is absolutely
because
what it's doing to the community what
it's doing to the world these little
anchors that are left
it's also doing inside you
right
so it's not just the people that are
coming together and looking all in the
same direction saying all the sames were
same words acknowledging you know uh
lifting up the highest thing it's also
happening inside you you're doing the
same thing because you're like the
community
you have all these thoughts you have all
these desires you have all these
purposes that are sometimes not in
alignment with each other right we have
that all in ourselves
but what are we doing when we come to
church and we stand and we look at the
altar and we
we we uh purposefully
try to set our minds straight to align
things in ourselves
in worship so that we also are
aligning we're we're bringing our things
together and obviously it's not i say
this it's not 100 you go back out all
the temptations are there you know
everything is there again but at least
to reset your alignment you know at
least to do that every week to come and
to reset and to commune to participate
with all these people in the same divine
mystery you are resetting yourself so
that you you have a little bit of a
little bit of alignment to go and to
preserve you for the rest of the week
and
and it's and it's
and like i said
we only know that to be true now so much
because we also see the opposite like if
you've had periods in your life or
you've been away from church if you know
people that have been away from church
you see it
the drifting
you know and this this this falling into
this kind of drifting
desire to stay amused to stay
entertained to stay
distracted
you know it's there it's so strong on
the outside we see it but and and we all
have that those temptations as well but
to come together at least
and for those that are able to do it
more than once a week thank god for that
if you have daily masses or if you have
vesper services and everything that's
wonderful but at least to come together
and to realign ourselves so that and
that gives us strength to face the crazy
insane fragmented world that we live in
and so like i said it's
there's a
there's a there's a traditional saying
which is that the the
the just holds the world together
right and and then uh
the idea that the prayers of the saints
are that which
hold the world together if we didn't
have
saints then the world would fall apart
and that is not just a
kind of speculative religious thing that
doesn't mean anything that is that is
really how the world works without nodes
without places without uh centers that
bring people together
then the world just fragments and falls
apart
and
and let's be honest if there ever is a
crisis what do you think is going to
happen in a world that is completely
fragmented
right if there's a if there's a major
crisis and and in our suburbs where you
barely know your neighbor two houses
down what do you think is going to
happen
it might not be pretty it might be an
opportunity though it might be an
opportunity for people to actually come
together but it can also be an
opportunity for everybody to rip each
other's hair out because we don't know
each other um we don't trust each other
and so that is the little encouragement
i wanted to give you to to remember that
as you
as you come to church you get dressed up
in the sunday morning and you make the
effort to to drive here
that you are not
that in a way it's not just for you
though it is for you
that you are actually holding the world
together to the extent that you're
participating in this divine mystery so
thank you
if anybody has any questions
[Applause]
why is
why are cities so important
in scripture
and how is it that we can um
reconstitute the medieval city
so
the story of the city in scripture is
actually an amazing
and very very important story
because
the story of the city is the story of
the fall actually
the if you look at how it develops in
scripture the people who found the first
cities are the descendants of cain
so kane actually founds the first city
and then his descendants are the one
that found not only the cities but all
everything you associate with human
activity in terms of science and
technology even arts music are all
developed by the descendants of cain
you think why is that why why is that
the reason is because as
the human person
fell from the garden in the garden adam
and eve are described as being naked
in in the tradition we say that they
were clothed in glory
that their communion with god and their
communion in the garden was sufficient
for them
but as they as they got further from the
glory of god then they had to protect
themselves from the world
right god said as they fell the result
is going to be thorns so you need to
protect yourself from the thorns
so what do you do you make a
clothing you put on clothing you
supplement your existence you add this
layer to you
in order to protect yourself
but then cain kills his brother
and he gets exiled further out so
imagine the garden as a mountain it's
the best way because it is a mountain
the map the garden of eden has a
mountain and when they fall they go they
leave the top of the mountain they go
out further
then they have to protect themselves
from the thorns and then uh cain kills
his brother and god says you need to go
further out keep going you have to go
further away from the garden so he goes
away and then there's more and more
hostility what does he have to do he has
to make
communal clothing
so we have personal clothing then we
have communal clothing and that's what a
city is you have a wall
and you have you have a wall just like
you wear clothing it's the same idea
okay
and so the the the city is an image of
this fall and this this necessity for
humans to supplement their existence in
order to survive in the world of death
and that grows and grows and grows and
gets bigger and gets bigger and then
finally weapons of war
war
the flood
right so it gets bigger and harder and
harsher and more protective and more
technological and everything and then
finally it all breaks down and the
waters come and wash it all away
so that is the cycle that's the cycle
that you see in in scripture in genesis
now
we're going through some something
similar right now i mean we're
definitely building up these walls
uh in a rather arrogant fashion because
we think they're going to protect us
now the wonderful thing about god is
that god takes death
and changes it into glory
god is constantly doing that taking
something which is dead
and transforming it filling it with
grace filling it with life
and that's the story so if you if you
understand that that is what god is
doing
the temple
the tabernacle
has the same structure that i told you
about
it has
it has a center like the center of the
garden
with the glory of god descending in the
middle and then it has a bunch of veils
all the way to the edge and at the edge
of the tabernacle tent they had animal
skins just like adam and eve were animal
skins it's a representation of the same
structure and then you can add to that
the city of jerusalem which is around it
and so god is taking something which is
actually a result of the fall and is
trying to change it into a glorious
thing and that's why at the end of
scripture the last image that is given
to us is a city
it's a glorious city it's a city made of
gems and gold and and it's a perfect
shape it's a cube actually if you look
at the measurements it's like this cube
and so from the garden
to the city that's the cycle of the fall
but now we have from the garden to the
city and it's the cycle of glory and god
takes everything this whole dark world
that we have all of this trash all of
the all of the bad intentions all of the
stuff that we're creating out of desire
to to give us our self power to give
ourselves to protect ourselves god
has shown us that he can transform it
into a glorious thing so the last image
that is given in scripture is of
the tree
that's there in the garden in the middle
of the city
with the river of life
and around it is the whole city so it's
like it's an image of everything
and the church has
that structure right that's why that's
why
christian churches were closed because
it also the church also represents the
new jerusalem
the the architecture of the church was
developed in an in a uh
apocalyptic vision right when you're in
the church the early churches all the
decorations of the churches were
apocalyptic it was christ returning it
was the the the beast chanting the glory
of god it was the the 24 uh the 24
elders you know in their white robes it
was all about
the end
and and so our church has that same
structure the same structure from the
garden with the altar and the
communion uh with the the host and the
communion chalice at the center
all the way out to
the gargoyles on the outside of the
church everything is there the whole
world is
represented in the way that the church
is set up
so it's to say that
there is nothing which is evil in itself
god god uses
the problem of evil is always a problem
of place it's a problem of
trying to put things where they're not
supposed to be
so if we have the wall on the outside
and the gargoyles on the outside that's
part of the the story
and in the inside we have the glory of
god there
the problem always happens when you try
to put the gargoyles in the sanctuary
don't put the gargoyles in the sanctuary
don't do that
does that help maybe understand a bit
why the city is so important in the
story
that was a long answer though sorry
could you comment on maybe family life
or some of our traditional practices
like maybe is it relevant to have
fasting and lent and meatless fridays
chapel veils those sort of things yeah
well one of the things one of the things
that um so i talked about space mostly
you know the city and all this i talked
about this this idea of bringing things
together
but there's also the problem of time
time has the same problem
time is this wheel that turns and and if
you're not careful it actually speeds up
something that people don't like to
relay but it's funny because now we can
realize it now because everybody noticed
i don't know
maybe i hope it's not just me but i know
everybody has noticed that time is
speeding up
the world is getting faster
and the reason why it's getting faster
is because of the fact that we have
destroyed our markers of time
we have destroyed the things which give
quality to time
and that's what our liturgical calendar
does
if you do not make time about
a cycle of you could call it something
like a normal cycle of repentance and
celebration
you could call it something like that
little death and glory it's like these
little moments where you repent and you
celebrate if you don't do that then
time's gonna get away from you
and you're going to start running like a
rat in a you know and start running like
a gerbil in a in a wheel and that's what
we we see around us so the
the idea of remembering saints
remembering christ participating in
these rituals that we do like fasting
like celebrating these different events
through the year like having
processions processions are great ways
to qualify space and to qualify time to
to give it meaning
right
uh to give meaning to time all of these
things are a way in which the world
actually we're holding things together
we're making things coherent
because like i said if you if that
breaks away then
you're i mean everybody we can see it
it's it's everywhere around us we see
everybody rushing like crazy people and
everybody running around like like like
mad people because we we've lost that
sense of ev being grateful and
participating in the thing that's why we
like we remember the saints every day we
have all these these like every day in
the in the church is a feast almost like
a feast of this saint and this stand
it's always a feast we're always we're
always celebrating something
and then there's also like i said the
fasting which is i uh let's say can i
say this a little death and a little
a little death all the time a little bit
of little add a little bit of repentance
and and and celebration
does that make sense
yeah i don't want to go into any like
specific thing but that's what in terms
of
how it holds the world together that's
what celebration does because we don't
what do we celebrate now what does our
world celebrate who knows
rock stars
uh
celebrities that's what we celebrate and
it's funny because we use the same
language for celebrities as we use for
saints call them stars we call them
idols we have all these words that we
use to to uh to like celebrate
celebrities for reasons that are not
nothing to celebrate um and when you
celebrate things that should not be
celebrated things that are related to
the passions things that are related to
our desires then you get pulled apart
you get ripped apart
and people get ripped apart in their
selves in their communities in their
marriages all of this is ripping people
apart depending on what they celebrate
because you can't avoid it
you have to celebrate that's what human
beings do we worship we're worship
creatures we celebrate things we
venerate things so what are you
venerating
and that's that's that's why we have to
remember that's why when we when we
celebrate our saints when we celebrate
the important events in the life of
christ in the life of the virgin in the
life of our of our communities as
churches we are
remembering and we are we are holding
together
we're holding ourselves together
i know you didn't want to get into
anything specific when it came to
symbolism
but um
as a new catholic i've never veiled in
chapel before um
chapel before um and i will today um
could you
explain the the symbolism of the
practice to help me to
internalize it for um for my experience
today
wow the veil
can ask me to talk about that
oh man talk about a minefield
um
no i i i'm okay to talk about that um so
the veil the veil there are two
i'm gonna focus on one reason there are
two reasons gonna focus on one which is
easier to focus on
the veil has to do with this this
mystery
one of the problems that happens with
the fall
is
we're away from the garden
right we're kind of we're kind of
removed from the garden and
we look at the garden from far away
now
christ has
given us a way to
receive from the holy place
and so
the the priest from the altar will bring
down
the divine presence into the church just
you know in a way that that is
making us participate in the incarnation
itself the the so from the holy place
comes this
this mystery but
the the this is going to get tough
because
in the traditional church in the ancient
church the the holy place had veils too
like in the orthodox church we still
have veils there's a veil which is just
like the veil in the temple there's a
there's a veil between the nave and the
altar
and and that veil is to help us
understand the distance
between us
and the holiest thing
now
in the in the in the temple the veil
never opened the veil was closed and
only one person in the entire in the
entire nation could go once a year into
the holy of holies
and they had to tie a rope to his in his
ankle because he could just die there
they would have to pull him out because
it was so closed off and holy whereas in
the in christianity christ has opened
the veil
but we still need the veil
because we if we don't have the veil
then we end up mistaking the mystery for
something lower than what it really is
now that's what happens
if you if if you don't have some form of
veil
between the holiest place and you even
that veil must open and things must come
but if you don't then what you end up
with in the end is you can you can get
communion in the mail
if you're a certain kind of protestant
and they send you little packets with
like a little bit of wine a little bit
of bread you can get it through the mail
and then you can just have it at home
while you're watching tv
right so what if you don't have that
veil you end up cheapening the mystery
to a point where it doesn't have any
mystery anymore okay and so the veil
is that that saint paul talks about the
veil that he asks women to wear that has
the same
meaning because each woman
is
a
possibly an image of the mother of god
is it possibly an image of the virgin
and just like the virgin is veiled just
like she is the holy of holies each
woman has the potential of
being that
for her husband
and so there's this there's this that's
why the one of the reasons why the veil
existed in the christian tradition
was to to create that to to preserve the
mystery of the holy place
that is one of the reasons
there's another reason which is more
complicated but i won't go into that one
but maybe that can help you a little bit
so i grew up in the suburbs of chicago
and you describe the experience
perfectly i mean it's endless sprawl
it's actually it's like an anti-garden
of eden in the sense of there's not even
a hill it's just totally flat
and there are churches but it definitely
doesn't bind together the community
but when i growing up in the 90s we had
the mall yeah and the mall actually did
it's not a sanctified place but it
definitely bound me and my friends and
you go there and there's a
you know pretty a lot of fond memories
of this showing away yeah shared
communal experience and all that
but now there's not even really they're
not it's going away the mall's going
away right so what do you see in your
you know studying different trends and
things like that what do you see
anything replacing
them all
the way you have to understand it is
like there's a hierarchy
in our human
in the way that humans function there's
there's a hierarchy and you can see it
you can see it in the medieval orders
where you had those that pray
right you had those that fight you had
those that work and in the ones that
worked you could kind of separate it
between those that were merchants and
those that really worked you kind of had
four classes of people right and so the
highest the spiritual rep is represented
by the church let's say and then after
that the the ones that fight would be
represented by the castle
or by the the the mayor's uh you know
like some kind of public building some
kind of public uh office building and
then you had the market
right
and then you had the land where people
worked so that hierarchy is the way that
the world exists you can't avoid it so
what happens is if you take the church
out you're like yeah we don't need this
what is it anyways we just come together
and we say a bunch of stuff like
internet's meaningless we just take that
away let's take that away what we can
find if we can find identity in our
nation
that we can find identity in that let's
forget the the upper part so then we say
like let's center it around our nation
then we have flags and we all stand
around the flag and we look at the flag
and we have you know different different
celebrations of our nation and there's
nothing wrong with that
but if you're taking out the top part
and you think you're going to find
resolution in the the lower part you're
in trouble
because that's going to start breaking
apart and then you say oh well then we
can find resolution in the market
right we can find resolution in the and
so the mall becomes the symbol of the
market and the market
the economy is what's going to hold us
together we don't have this identity in
the nation anymore we don't have this
identity in the spiritual world anymore
but the market the economy is what's
going to hold us together we go to the
mall and we're all together but that's
not going to hold
it's not going to hold
so you're not surprised you can't be
surprised that that the mall is going
away and that we're all going to end up
fragmented alone on our computers
shopping on amazon and finding these
weird distributed communities online and
not interacting with our neighbors
ordering food even you couldn't have to
get out of your house you could order
food your house and you never have to
leave
right so it's like these these
completely fragmented individuals that
exist sprawled out on a land now what's
going to replace it
everybody's looking to try to figure it
out
people are doing weird things to try to
figure out doing uh you know like
star wars
and and and marvel movies and uh harry
potter that's where they're trying
everybody's trying to find some kind of
thing that's going to unite them and
then political ideology people get into
their these weird political clans and
they fight amongst each other because
this this unity they feel like this is
giving them purpose and giving them
giving them reason
and the last message is these weird
online communities that are not united
in space but are weirdly united just on
the internet but that's nothing
like those people are not going to help
you
if you're in trouble
if you fall in a ditch i don't see where
those people are going to help you and
so
the only solution and and i say this
because i have gone i've gone through
the effort to think like what really
is the way the only way and the only way
is the return
to
the church there's there's no other way
and it and i'm saying this not just
because i'm a christian just because
just because i'm uh
i'm saying this because
this is really how the world works
like without the top part everything
else starts to fragment
there's no way out of it yeah
i've watched your commentary on moana
and and
the sacred femininity
could you explain that to me and uh
sacred femininity and why it's important
for us to sort of follow
patriarchy
so the problem let me let me phrase it
this way
now
the problem with the idea of patriarchy
is that it doesn't totally understand
how things work
it doesn't understand that
there's that which is said and there's
that which is unsaid
there's that which is hierarchy under
that and there's that which is not
hierarchy
and you need both
the problem happens when one tries to be
the other
okay
so you can understand it as the
masculine aspect of society and of of
culture represents
the hierarchy
right it manifests the hierarchy but you
don't you can't just have hierarchy
it doesn't work that way you also need
you also need the
let's say the the unsaid
private the feminine the space in which
the world takes place the the holy place
in which the world is unfolding
and that that manifests itself as the
the bringing potentiality the questions
the uh the frame of of the world all of
these things are are what the feminine
bring to the world now the problem is
that the problem is that we actually
don't value that
our society does it doesn't value that
they are our hyper
the modern world is actually hyper
masculine
and the trick and the the seduction that
has happened is that somehow this hyper
masculine world has convinced the
feminine that it has to be like the
masculine
that the only value that exists is to be
to be masculine
to get in that hierarchy you know you
need to get that high position in a job
you need to you need to to go to to to
scale up the the hierarchy of the world
and and be represented in all these
different aspects of hierarchy and it's
like
that's a problem
that's a real problem because the the
private space is shrinking the private
our private world our secret world of
the family the place where we where we
where we where we discover that
togetherness in that intimacy is
shrinking at an incredible rate and
marriages are breaking apart families
are being shattered all of this is
happening
because we don't value the feminine
because we don't value that that that
that that secret place that we all
gather together we don't value that
place
um and so
one of the one of the things when i talk
about that people
think that i'm somehow promoting
patriarch i'm not promoting patriarchy i
think i think i think that we need the
hierarchy and we need the space
and and i actually believe that the
problem of the modern world that we
haven't valued
the the
holy place we just haven't and we need
to do that and in the moana video what i
was trying to show in in those types of
videos is that
they somehow think that they're giving
value to the feminine character by
showing her supplant this male character
and and and and by removing the normal
interaction between the the masculine
and the feminine putting the putting the
feminine space but then also having a
feminine character who's interacting in
a masculine way with the feminine space
it's like you're you're destroying the
world when you're doing that
right because that's not how the world
works
does that make sense a little bit
thank you again
i'm sure you have a lot of thoughts and
questions and things are going on i
encourage you to go online and to follow
jonathan his youtube videos a lot of
great explanation the conversation can
continue certainly online we're also
delighted to have jonathan join us today
for our liturgy later on today for the
feast of christ the kings we're very
excited but thank you again it's been an
absolute joy and thanks for being with
us here in chicago
[Applause]